promo c'est le droit de retrait qui
effectivement dans le code du travail
donc il a tout son sens mais si on
utilise avec abu comparé à 10,1 pays
pourront droit de retrait alors je pense
que aussi bien les travailleurs de la
cft eu les actionnaires de la cft eu le
président de la cité
le chargé du transport de la cité m me
le préfet par se mettre autour d'une
table
vous pouvez enfin règlement intérieur
puisqu'on nous dit que ça bloque si ce
règlement était ailleurs faisons le
rapidement et définitivement ou que
quand il y ait un droit de grève cela
existe déjà le service minimum mais que
quand il ya un droit de retrait justifié
on ne paralyse pas tout un pays